then the last one is sock puppets I know
I know it sounds ridiculous but you're
not getting paid until you do it plus it
says it's a lot of fun on the other hand
it is a sock puppet saying that I don't
know if you can really take his word for
it
[Music]
okay those are great actually
so let's use them this is so dumb dude
it's not about you okay sock up use the
puppet fine this is dumb
almost as dumb is not drinking for an
entire week everything you don't want to
do is dumb and fart she's a genius idea
yeah you're once Adams right Blake it's
time you grew up and put your time
towards something that's worth something
to somebody anywhere on this planet good
um don't tell me what to do you're not
the boss of me you fake-ass grown up I'm
sorry maybe if you weren't so immature I
wouldn't have to hold your hand and wipe
her ass for you okay that was one time
and I told you I've never been camping
before hey guys why don't we talk about
me now of course who could forget you I
love how it takes us to quit drinking -
remember how selfish Adam the main
attraction demand really is oh I like
how you using that nickname to hurt my
feelings but guess what on ders I love
it and I'm gonna use it all the time now
do you ever stop talking
haha yeah Blake I'll agree but at least
he knows how to write a rent check on
time like an adult hmm oh you want me to
grow up
yeah I'm immature I'm real immature but
I'm immature because I know when I grow
up it means I'm gonna be that much
closer to moving away from you guys and
Marion girls and stuff come on man don't
say that no he's right
I'm sorry too I know I could be
self-centered sometimes but I never
heard no growing up now that I've logged
10,000 hours of being a brat I'm just a
total self-serving outlier and that's
not out Adam the main attraction to man
wants to live no man
Adam looked it's hard to say no to that
face too cute one I know I could be
controlling sometimes but it's just
because I care about you and I want the
best for you what's best and that's that
scares me life is scary I know that I
could tell you guys this you won't judge
me
I like that was intense